we call this the Minneapolis  Miracle trivia game how much time was on  the clock when the ball snapped 14 [ __ ]  he was close ten ten seconds damn what  down was it third it was third down what  color jersey was you wearing oh I said  senior purple what what cleats did you  have on the DS2 the future cleats yeah  yeah  I was going up before the game the two  closest Defenders when you caught the  ball Kenny Kenny something  he's having a good ass career too like  celebration as you cross the goal line  oh yeah I tossed that one [ __ ] like I  was uh what's that thing are you not  entertained I think I was like a show  bro we need to make that a movie first  person that you hugged after it was  Caleb Jones like  um he was like one of those guys that  was pulling for me during the year like  so he was ran on the field and gave me  the biggest hug I was like this man I  love you bro